madre adhère merci d'être avec nous en
direct un vos propos ont été
retranscrits dans le sujet que l'on
vient de diffuser vous dit avoir alerté
sur le drame qui s'est produit à six
reprises qui avez-vous prévenu et que
vous êtes ont répondu comme un bonbon
bonjour à vous tous et bienvenue pour le
président marc l'homme monsieur match
long au liban je fais quelque chose qui
on a rappelé aux valves au liban qui dit
peut-être quelque chose de négatif va
devenir positif pour nous peut-être que
la collaboration et la coopération est
la seule à dire et un solidarité entre
mots et la france va devenir le plus
solide et plus productives et pourquoi
on est en train de réformer notre
administration d'un brigand
l'administration publique ont fait plus
fort parce que vous avez déjà et c'est
quelque chose de la corruption au liban
et on a un niveau de corruption
pas mal j'ai déjà fait à la douane les
cuissons de douane
le direction générale un plan
stratégique pour la lutte contre la
corruption parce que la plupart de notre
problème est notre cas tu as tort mêmes
effets liés à la corruption y est c'est
au liban durant ses vannes et dernière
designer de l'année
c'est ce qu'on fait maintenant à propos
de cette catastrophe
à propos du nitrate d'ammonium ont fait
l'investigation judiciaire et aussi
l'investigation admiratif on a deux
d'investigation qui sont parallèles
l'assa 2 malgré tout ça on a
malheureusement on a catastrophe à cause
peut-être de mal de gestion de
l'entrepôt mal de gestion de deux
d'imagerie nages parce qu'il faut des
magasins bien spécifiques
tout ce qui est capable tout ce qui est
pour ce qui est
avec 12 buts selon les inondations on a
des côtes dans les fps code et c'est
pourquoi le maroc à 20 mn ont maintenant
à propos de l'irak d'ammonium est créée
la lèvre comme l'avait déjà quitté mais
juste puisque d'air qui avez vous prévu
c'est six fois précise et qu'est ce
qu'on vous a répondu exactement
l'autorité judiciaire qui a qui a déjà
sévi en substance parce qu'elle est une
quantité énorme et même il y à il y
avait quelque chose de dangereux
c'est quelque chose de dangereux pour
nos crèches qui pourrait employer pour y
gagner
et pourquoi j'ai fait la largeur et la
lave à un juge qui a déjà saisi qui a
pris la décision de saisir et c'est ce
que j'ai proposé au juge de 2,2 obligé
de prendre une décision pour la
l'obligation de la compagnie maritime
pour remporter cette substance testeurs
tous à 2700 tonnes
c'est pourquoi malgré ta dans le magasin
il y avait le pot numéro 12 qui est
spécialisé pour les produits chimiques
mais peut-être fait pas spécialisés pour
quelque chose comme nitra cette quantité
de nitrate d'ammonium m l'entretien de
ce magasin ou la maintenance de la forge
réponse de l'administration des deux
ports de bayrou s'il ya une
administration aux exploitations et la
gestion du port de bâle yb rhdp qui est
responsable de ceux de 50 monsieur d'air
monsieur des qui a pris à la décision de
décharger le bateau est donc de stocker
ces milliers de tonnes de nitrate
d'ammonium dans le port de beyrouth qui
a décidé cela hélas son journal de
transport qui est lié au ministère de
cause de travaux de transformer les
non aucune responsabilité selon vous pas
du tout pas du tout envie nash y ait des
charges et décharges et à la douane
c'est pas la responsabilité de la douane
nous sommes bien déterminés nous avons
une mission bien déterminée et la
collection de taxes de douane et de tva
de taxe à valeur ajoutée alors que l'on
comprenne bien justement quelle est la
mission des douaniers et qu'elle est
celle des autorités portuaires
manifestement vous n'avez pas nouvelle
oui pas la même pas du tout préparés
aussi indépendant les autorités
douanières ont lié à la halle au
ministère des finances met en ligne une
administration un dea en tout à fait de
l'administration et l'exploitation du
port de beyrouth qui est lié au
ministère des transports et des travaux
publics etc c'est pourquoi chacun a
autorité spécifique et missions
spécifiques et bien déterminés et on
peut passer quelque chose de l'ordre
public on appelle en droit c'est en loi
parce qu' on peut pas recruter en
mission d'accord alors monsieur r si je
comprends bien vous étiez au courant
qu'il y avait deux mille sept cent
cinquante tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
qui étaient stockés dans le port de
beyrouth
et est ce que la part de responsabilité
ne commence-t-elle pas là au moment à
partir du moment où vous saviez qu'il y
avait une bombe à retardement qui
étaient stockés dans le for like en
entrée est une autre chose de la mission
ou de l'autorité quand j'ai su m'ajuster
depuis deux ans devant et quelques mois
j'ai su qu'ils avaient ça parce qu'il
est il y avait un autre directeur
général pour moi et quand jésus j'ai
envoyé deux lettres pour le juge parce
que c'est quelque chose judiciaire
vous savez on a quatre autorités au
libor autorités judiciaires et l
dépendant de l'autorité exécutive même
elle est indépendante et on n'a pas
aussi l'autorité de m 2
de gamme et désordre pour même des
propositions aussi mais ce que j'ai
proposé est quelque chose de
supplémentaire pour mon travail je parte
il parce que c'est quelque chose qui qui
est liée à la sécurité des brigadiers et
d'officiers de demain mon administration
et d autres l'adminstration alors vous
dites que les douanes les services de
douanes n'ont aucune responsabilité dans
ce drame vous avez également dit que ça
pourrait des travaux de rénovation menés
sous l'égide des autorités portuaires
qu'elle veut et déco j'ai donc ces
explosions meurtrières vous dit ne
vouloir accuser personne
or le message est bien coeur vous dit
que des autorités portuaires ont fauté
l'investigation qui va décider
enfin parce qu'il ya une investigation
concerne l'investigation vous allez
avoir le résultat officiel de la
responsabilité mais bien sûr que on a
pas aucune responsabilité à propos du
magasinage et de choisir le magasin et
de choisir les îles conscience de tout
ce qui est magasinage et spécialement de
tout ce qui est valable marchandises
alors pour l'heure tous les responsables
en pouvant avoir joué un rôle en et
éventuellement failli dans leur mission
sont placés sous la surveillance de la
justice est ce que vous savez qui
s'accomplit est ce que ça vous concerne
c' est le juge qui a pris la décision
-peut-être il ne savait pas que fait
quelque chose qui est dangereux c'est
pourquoi j'ai tiré la leyre à à ses
juges et sais pas mais ma mon autorité
et ma mission et mon travail
elle doit arrêter quelque part là où ça
commence tout ce qui est procédure
judiciaire vous savez fait le français
au liban où on a les lois d'origine
française et jusqu'à maintenant on a la
loi de douane et la côte de douala
elle est justement plus conforme de la
côte de douane chantelle et même le la
fin de l'année
on de l'exploitation des deux ports dvi
route est aussi une copie de
l'exploitation du port en sus des
remercie d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes directeur
général des douanes libanaises et que
vous étiez en direct sur rt franz marty